elles sont toutes les heures ou presque
la cloche de l'église du monastère donne
le ton et rythme le temps
derrière ces murs vivent 13 monial qui
ont choisi d'intégrer la congrégation
des bénédictines
la plus jeune à 51 ans la plus âgée 90
elles se sont toutes engagées de manière
définitive après avoir prononcé les voeu
d'obéissance de pauvreté de chasteté et
de stabilité ce matin là et dès 6 heures
25 c'est le début de la journée pour
sera les le mari ça c'est une autre
manière ce qu'on appelle la cool
c'est
d'ailleurs tout à fait je revêts le
christ c'est une croix un lycée un grand
habit en forme de croix
sera le mari commence toujours sa
journée en chantant
[Musique]
de une louange qui va de soi pour celles
qui dans une autre vie fut enseignante
auprès des sous
tous les matins c'est le même rituel
presque au pas de course les moniales
sont conviés au mode le premier office
de la journée
un temps de prières chantées plutôt
joyeux en fait la résurrection du christ
[Musique]
ce premier office dure une demi-heure
après les psaumes direction de
réfectoire pour le petit les jeunes et
il est encore très tôt et il faut déjà
travailler pour soral et le mari c'est
la cuisine
pourquoi j'ai besoin de travailler
et pourquoi vous travaillez pourquoi les
gens travaillent on est comme les autres
on est on travaille pour d'abord pour se
nourrir ensuite pour subvenir aux
besoins de la communauté et pour aussi
entretenir tous ces bâtiments je pense
qu'il faut quand même avoir un peu de de
matière pour les entretenir et l'argent
ne tombe pas du ciel pour nous non plus
donc vraiment on est lié à tous ceux qui
travaillent
le travail fait partie intégrante de la
vie monastique
et même la patronne du monastère sur
marie caroline participe elle aussi aux
tâches domestiques
même les plus ingrates
voilà comme le christ s'est mis à jour
au pied de serre et de ses disciples je
crois que c'est pas forcément ce geste
symbolique il faut refaire tout le temps
mais c'est une façon de faire me faire
un dessin c'est une façon de se mettre
aux pieds
si j'avais te passer de vaisselle voilà
deux
soeurs marie caroline est aussi une
universitaire
et si sa vocation ne fait plus aucun
doute aujourd'hui ses débuts dans la vie
religieuse ont été parfois chaotique
moi ça m'a beaucoup frappé quand je suis
rentré monastère que j'allais rentrer
dans une dans une école il est comme
prestigieuse
école
où vous allez apprendre l'amour parce
que j'arrivais avec toutes les illusions
croyant que c'était passé
je me suis vite aperçu que supporter ses
soeurs au jour le jour ce n'est pas
forcément l'événement
mais que j'allais j'allais être la place
et que tous les jours je constate qu'il
faut que je réapprenne parce que
j'ai des sentiments négatifs qui
m'habite la violence
j'ai pas envie d'aimer
soeur marie caroline a été élu maire
prieur à l'âge de 41 ans
c'est son troisième mandat élu à
l'unanimité
son rôle garder l'unité de la communauté
et ça n'est pas toujours ça cet après
midi là il ya réunion du conseil la se
décide en cercle restreint les décisions
importantes à prendre ce jour-là on
assiste à une petite révolution des
objectifs on les a mis ici permettre à
des jeunes de découvrir toujours plus le
christ comme europe et comme chemin qui
donne sens à leur vie
le monastère de bouzy veut ouvrir ses
portes à des jeunes pour partager sur un
temps assez long la vie monastique au
plus près
les habitudes des moniales en seront
forcément bouleversé puisque nous avons
choisi une vie de retrait c'est donc pas
forcément évident de d'ouvrir ses portes
à des jeunes qui arrivent du monde avec
tout ce qu'elles sont il faudra
forcément les accueillir telles qu'elles
sont donc je peux comprendre que ça que
ça puisse générer quelques quelques
peurs chez
j'ai des soeurs
dans un monastère s'il ya une chose qui
ne changera probablement jamais c'est le
silence des lieux ici on parle peu ou
pas et le silence commence dect redon a
franchi la clôture l'espace de vie
réservée aux moniales
c'est que c'est un lieu de ses noces et
quand vous rencontrez d'autres soeur
alors vous n'avez pas de quoi vous
parlez donc en général qu'on se parle
pas nous on se salue on essaye de
montrer simplement concept vu et on se
se saluer mais on ne parle pas si on
désire se parler ou s'éloigne on se met
dans un compliment pour essayer de pas
gêner tout le monde d'autant plus que
c'est un milieu qui résonne pas mal donc
quand on parle on entend
même les repas sont pris sans paroles
seul une soeur chaque jour fait lecture
d'un article ou d'un ouvrage religieux 1
ce matin là c'était un extrait du livre
de la sociologue elena lasida sur la
question du temps
le temps et de l'argent
c'est une phrase que l'on entend
habituellement dans le domaine
économique
car le temps est considéré en économie
comme une ressource à optimiser il faut
faire vite pour produire plus envoie de
temps possible
il s'élance fait partie de votre vie oui
ne pourrais pas vivre si on était
toujours dans la parole serait ce serait
insupportable le silence c'est des
moments où où se
se ressource littéralement
le silence c'est pas un absolu en soit
dans le sens où c'est pas c'est pas un
but voilà c'est pour écouter quelqu'un
et pour écouter il faut qu'on ait des
moments de silence des par exemple joie
le le les repas c'est un moment où on
est en silence et c'est capital en tout
cas pour moi c'est capital ne pas avoir
à gérer la parole parce que de gérer la
parole dans une communauté c'est pas
toujours facile
certes elles ont choisi une vie retirée
du monde mais cela ne veut pas dire
qu'elles ne sortent jamais
il est formellement interdit de se
moquer d'une soeur qui conduit un vieux
camion
[Rires]
petit à petit les moniales aussi se
mettent à l'écologie ou du moins au tri
des déchets
papier carton verre tout ce qui est
recyclable sera transférée à la
déchetterie voisine située à bréhan vrai
autrefois l'essor de santé par les
dentistes venez au monastère les
médecins venez au monastère et obtenu
auprès serbe ne sortait que pour des cas
d'hospitalisation
mais mais voilà maintenant s'ouvrir
davantage
voilà il ya une soeur qui est parti là
elle est partie en sessions de chant à
la pierre qui vire c'était bien dans le
morvan
et si ces sorties sont plus fréquentes
contre x pour les soeurs cela doit quand
même rester l'exception
qui va des cartons
ma vie à l'intérieur du monastère ne me
suffit ça suffit je vous dis c'est une
vie heureuse je vois pas pourquoi j'ai
chercher ailleurs ce que j'ai à la
maison voilà c'est ça et en même temps
comme je disais ça nous arrive de sortir
d'aller faire une session quelque part
on est heureuse de revenir à je peux
vous le dire après une semaine à aller
auf on rentre à la maison et on est bien
quoi
contente de rentrer à la maison pour les
retrouver leur tranquillité mais
contente surtout de renouer avec ce qui
fait l'essentiel de leur existence une
vie de prière rythmée par les neuf
offices de la journée il est 18 heures
ce jour-là c'est le temps de l'oraison
les moniales peuvent se placer là où
elles le veulent sera les le mari a
choisi de ses genoux y est moi je
préfère être dans cette position je suis
bien parce que je suis détendu et j'ai
une ouverture si vous voulez nous
verture physique il ça commence par le
physique l'ouverture je sens que mon
coeur s'ouvre comme comme s'ils avaient
une ouverture la voilà et je laisse
l'esprit saint pénétrer en moi je laisse
les plus sains vivre en moi
il faut entretenir ce climat de dialogue
avec dieu la prière c'est un dialogue on
écoute dieu et on lui répond donc pour
entretenir ce climat de prière
continuelle on a besoin parce qu'on est
incarné de le manifester par des temps
régulier à l'église s'il n'y a pas ça on
peut pas tenir
[Musique]
entre la prière et le travail les
journées des moniales sont bien chargées
il est 21h30 se remarie caroline se
dirige enfin vers sa cellule
[Applaudissements]
pour les bénédictines la cellule est un
lieu d'intimité est essentielle pour y
dormir bien sûr mais aussi pour prier
travailler et se ressourcer
puis c'est un lieu très important
la cellule d'une soeur ça n'est pas plus
de 12 m² composé d'un lit d'une table et
d'un prix lieu et ça n'est pas forcément
austère
les des cellules de seurre que j'ai déjà
vu sur ce père austère n'y a rien et
puis moi j'ai toujours un peu de ça
voilà ça c'est une question de
tempérament et cartes postales oui voilà
c'est moi j'aime bien
voilà j'ai besoin d'avoir un peu de
calme et l'icône d'avoir aussi des
livres moi c'est j'adore boucle et donc
j'ai besoin d
être monial c'est être retirée du monde
jusque dans la mort
la joute au cimetière nous allons
rencontrer la communauté du ciel
ah oui
c'est là où sont enterrés toutes nos
soeurs
depuis que nous sommes ici c'est à dire
de plus 20 ans eh bien il ya maintenant
13 heures au cimetière et 13h en
communauté égalité alors maintenant
qui va gagner
c'est donc à quelques mètres du
monastère que sont enterrés les soeurs
de bouzy la forêt
accompagné par la communauté jusqu'au
dernier souffle alors la dernière 6
heures marie bernard
voilà 2018 juste le 1er avril on va
fêter son premier anniversaire là
c'était le jour de pâques le matin de
pâques c'est quand même magnifique ça de
mourir un matin de pâques nous on a dit
roy moi j'ai une des premières paroles
ça a été dire alléluia
et si leur vie est principalement
tournée vers la prière et le travail le
rire et la bonne humeur ont aussi toute
leur place et ses défunts général de
l'onm h heure grâce aux tentes des
tentes consacré ce jour-là à l'épluchage
des pommes les moniales se lâche un peu
laissez-moi vous remercier sharma
marie-caroline d'avoir organisé cette
session cible si riche en rencontres
échangés conférence de grande qualité
oui j'en pouvais plus en lisant ça
c'est quand même un critère de
discernement
si si on sent quelqu'un entre au
monastère et tire toujours une tête
comme ça est triste c'est clair et net
qui ne l'a sûrement pas une vocation à
rentrer à rentrer chez nous
[Musique]
toutes vos le diront la vie monastique
n'est pas un long fleuve tranquille
car la fois c'est aussi une question
d'endurance chaque jour les moniales
doivent avoir la volonté de croire
il arrive que certaines soeur qui ne se
sont plus en phase avec cette vie quitte
le monastère et c'est déjà arrivé à
bouzy celles qui restent ont trouvé leur
équilibre et pour rien au monde ne
changerait de vie
souvent jeudi si je devais recommencer
je recommence
malgré les difficultés et les moments de
doute que j'ai eu au début de ma de ma
vie monastique parce que justement j'ai
eu l'impression de commencer un voyage
intérieur une aventure qui n'a pas été
sans sans peur et sans moments
difficiles mais que pour rien au monde
je ne je ne récuse je ne refuse parce
que
[Musique]